what we want to do is find the
derivative of this g of x and at first
it could look intimidating we have a
sine of x here we have a cosine of x we
have this crazy
expression here we have a pi over cube
root of x we're squaring the whole thing
at first it might seem intimidating but
as we'll see in this video we can
actually do this with the tools already
in our toolkit using our existing
derivative properties using what we know
about the power rule which tells us the
derivative with respect to x
of x to the n
is equal to n times x to the n minus 1
we've seen that multiple times
we also need to use the fact that the
derivative of cosine of x
is equal to negative sine of x and the
other way around the derivative with
respect to x of sine
of x
is equal to positive cosine of x so
using just that we can actually evaluate
this or evaluate g prime of x so pause
the video and see if you can do it
so probably the most intimidating part
of this because we know the derivative
of sine of x and cosine of x is this
expression here and we can just rewrite
this or simplify it a little bit so it
takes a form that you might be a little
bit more familiar with so actually let
me just do this on the side here so pi
pi
over
the cube root of x
squared well that's the same thing this
is equal to
pi squared over the cube root of x
squared this is just exponent properties
that we're dealing with and so this is
the same thing we're going to take x to
the one third power and then raise that
to the second power so this is equal to
pi squared over
let me write it this way i'm not going
to skip any steps because this is a good
review of exponent properties x to the
one third squared
which is the same thing as pi
squared over x to the two thirds power
which is the same thing as pi squared
times x to the negative two thirds power
so when you write it like this it starts
to get into a form you're like oh i
could see how the power rule could apply
there so this thing is just pi squared
times x to the negative two thirds power
so actually let me delete this
so
this thing
can be rewritten
this thing can be rewritten as
pi
squared times x to the negative
to the negative
two thirds power so now let's take the
derivative of each of each of these each
of these pieces of this expression
so we're going to take where you want to
evaluate what g prime of x is
so g prime of x is going to be equal to
you could view it as the derivative with
respect to x of 7 sine of x
so
we could take let's do the derivative
operator on both sides here just to make
it clear of what we're doing
so we're going to apply it there we're
going to apply it
there
and we're going to apply it there
so this derivative this is the same
thing as
this is going to be 7 times the
derivative of sine of x so this is just
going to be 7 times cosine of x
this one over here this is going to be 3
or we're subtracting so it's going to be
this subtract this minus we can bring
the
the constant out that we're multiplying
the expression by and the derivative of
cosine of x so it's minus 3 times the
derivative of cosine of x is negative
sine of x
negative
sine of x
and then finally
here in the yellow we just apply the
power rule
so we have the negative two-thirds
actually let's not forget this minus
sign i'm going to write it out here so
you have the negative two-thirds you
multiply the exponent times the
coefficient it might look confusing pi
squared but that's just a number so it's
going to be
negative and then you have negative
two-thirds
times pi squared
times pi squared
times x to the negative two-thirds minus
one power negative two-thirds
minus 1 power so what is this going to
be
so we get g prime of x is equal to
is equal to 7
cosine of x
and let's see we have a negative 3 times
a negative sine of x so that's a
positive
3
sine of x
and then
we have we're subtracting but then this
is going to be a negative so that's
going to be a positive so we could say
plus
2 pi squared over 3
2 pi
squared over 3 that's that part there
times
x
to the
so negative two-thirds
minus one we could say negative one and
two thirds or we could say negative five
thirds power
negative
five thirds power and there you have it
we were able to tackle this thing that
looked a little bit hairy but all we had
to use was the power rule and what we
knew to be the derivatives of sine and
cosine